all right before i get to all of the
breaking news today and there is a lot
i want to take a minute i want to say
something
i have never witnessed a speech on the
u.s senate floor that was as powerful
as the speech today given by senator
collins of maine her remarks today
i've been in talk radio now 30 years
tomorrow incidentally
i begin my 23rd year here at the fox
news channel
it was frankly the best speech i ever
witnessed in the u s senate
it was an example on how all senators
should make decisions
and conduct themselves senator collins
was methodical
thoughtful respectful clearly did her
homework
laid out her judicial philosophy that of
judge kavanaugh
she showed a grasp of the constitution
supreme court precedence
and she gave a chilling and sad
description of the environment that
we're all living in today
it was truly a modern-day profile in
courage
frankly i don't know susan collins and i
don't know well at all
i don't get impressed that often but the
speech today
it frankly blew me away and she should
be proud
and frankly it had a lot less to do with
her decisional that's very important in
all of this
than the pure human decency fairness
and process that she employed to get to
her decision
let's take a look today
we have come to the conclusion of a
confirmation
process that has become so
dysfunctional it looks more like a
caricature of a gutter level
political campaign than a solemn
occasion judge kavanaugh has received
rave reviews for his 12-year track
record as a judge
including for his judicial temperament
the american bar association gave him
its highest possible rating in
evaluating any given claim of misconduct
we will be
ill-served in the long run if we
abandon the presumption of
innocence and fairness i listened
carefully to christine blasey ford's
testimony before the judiciary committee
i found her testimony to be
sincere painful
and compelling the four witnesses she
named
could not corroborate any
of the events of that evening gathering
where she says the assault occurred
none of the individuals professor ford
says we're at the party
has any recollection at all
of that night the facts presented
do not mean that president that
professor
ford was not sexually assaulted that
night
or at some other time but they
do lead me to conclude that the
allegations failed to me
be more likely than not standard
therefore i do not believe that these
charges can fairly prevent
judge kavanaugh from serving on the
court
mr president i will vote
to confirm judge kavanaugh
i have not always agreed with senator
collins and
even some things she said in her speech
i disagree with in terms of precedence
and the law
that's not the issue she bravely
restored common sense
decency to the u.s senate today and led
by example
and she had to stand up to a very angry
left-wing
mob and she stood for principles that
make this country great
showed real courage now she took this
process from the very beginning
seriously she protected the sanctity
of the u.s constitution due process
presumption of innocence
and in doing so she exposed what is the
hyper partisan
frankly destructive nature of so many
smear merchants
that exist on the left today and by the
way there are some on the right too
senator lindsey graham who's going to be
joining us in a few minutes with senator
ted cruz
he also tonight deserves a lot of credit
his powerful moment
it lit a fire for truth justice and
decency
in this country many democrats proclaim
their opposition to judge kavanaugh
within seconds of his nomination others
upended his hearings with
endless interruptions grandstanding the
worst of the worst
and then worst of all many seventh
democrats
actually went along with accusing brett
kavanaugh
of even being a rapist a gang rapist
no presumption of innocence at all
drugging girls
routinely at parties they called him
evil compared him to bill cosby
men were told to sit down and shut up
they did this with zero corroborating
evidence
and based on 36-year old claims
that were backed up by nobody the
republicans took this
rightly serious it's a serious topic
lawmakers
some of them they didn't care they
wanted to ruin a man's life
and his reputation forever and i'm
pretty certain tonight
brett kavanaugh his wife his two young
daughters
i'm sure they'll never be the same again
we as a country cannot reward
this madness meanness insanity
now many on the left they're lashing out
at senator collins predictably
an opinion website owned by univision
called splinter
published a piece entitled bleep susan
collins
it's all over the place if you look
don't even read social media
you know nut jobs so-called comedian
kathy griffin you know the one that had
the severed head of donald trump
telling collins to go to hell tonight
and the official twitter
of the women's march published this
picture call senator
susan collins a quote rape apologist
this is so over the top so
so despicably ugly and disgusting
wouldn't many of these same people that
claim to
have a monopoly of compassion for women
minorities
human civil rights wouldn't they be
showing
outrage if any conservative in this
country ever said and did such things
it's a very dangerous time for this
country weeks prior to her speech
susan collins had left-wing activists
sending thousands of coat hangers to her
office they made threatening derogatory
calls to her staff
they tried to bribe her with a
crowdfunding campaign
and an angry mob of left-wing protesters
harassing senators
all over capitol hill this is now
getting dangerous take a look
very much
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
now let me say something and i really
believe the people should be close to
their elected representatives
and it's sad what i'm about to say
before
somebody gets hurt or worse
these office areas of elected officials
now need to be closed to the public
sad but it needs to happen this is now
dangerous and out of control and of
course the left
predictably acting out in ways on tv
that are frankly unconscionable many
cases on so-called news networks take a
look
when not if when judge kavanaugh helps
them to chip away
at civil rights voting rights women's
rights abortion rights
i don't think it's going to sit very
well with the country let's not forget
these people would go to church
and then go to the lynching after
clothing themselves and morality and
that's what
we're seeing today clearly the
republicans don't care about the truth
they didn't want an investigation into
who brett kavanaugh really was
and that's what was gutless but
unfortunately we are where we are and
this is a travesty for america right now
the the problem with america right now
is that we've lost a moral compass
now for the last 22 days we americans we
have witnessed
what is an unrivaled insanity a madness
that has taken over
and it is now shaking the very core
principles that
every one of us doesn't matter about
politics should be holding near and dear
to our hearts
rule of law due process presumption of
innocence
and democrats well are we going to
reward this behavior
shouldn't people be facing consequences
for what is
reckless actions senator feinstein she
may now be the
subject of an ethics probe over who
leaked professor ford's letter
now a witness tampering investigation
should take place
after claims that one of professor
ford's close friends
who she listed to corroborate her story
admitted to the fbi that she was being
pressured into altering her statement
all of this aside in 32 days
there is now we've all learned something
there is something a lot more profound
on the ballot than anybody is talking
about or telling you
on the one side we now have
one party in america by the way i want
to purposely exclude joe manchin
of west virginia that have become a
party
that has been overtaken by the far left
they don't even have room for joe
lieberman in this party remember what
they did to him in connecticut i've
known joan lieberman
for decades one of the nicest people
you'll ever meet
we have now witnessed in 22 days a party
that clearly stands for a type of
government
that is alien to everything that this
country we love was founded on
a party rejecting and simply just
hating what we all thought we agreed on
core
basic fundamental principles rejecting
even our constitution demanding full and
complete conformity if you don't agree
god help you a party of blatant double
standards
that can remain totally silent about
gross allegations
against keith ellis and bill clinton
they can love the clintons
but pretend to care about being the
champions of women's rights
obviously selective moral outrage it's a
party that envisions their ideology
and agenda spread through the courts
they want
activist judges they want legislation uh
from that they could never get past
themselves done
from the court they don't want
separation of powers co-equal branches
this is what has made this confirmation
process
so political it shouldn't matter tonight
there is zero gloating here or
i wanted brett kavanaugh to win because
i thought he deserved the position and i
thought i'd
agree with his judicial philosophy i
don't care if you're a republican a
democrat liberal or conservative
what we have been watching the last 22
days in this country
this is not justice and in 32 days from
now
human rights will be on the ballot
treating every american with fundamental
fairness respect equal justice under the
law
equal application of our laws that is on
the ballot
in 32 days you think of the sacrifice of
our founders our framers
in 32 days after what we have now lived
through
this will be about affirming american
history and values
that they all fought bled died for
sacrifice for us due process
presumption of innocence why is that
ever political
constitutional rights civil liberties
in 32 days you we the people have a
choice
to reaffirm these values these
principles that so many brave men and
women
fought many died for those who
understood the values of freedom
and justice it made this country great
and it has served us well
in 32 days this election is about
preserving
all that is good and right and just in
this country
and taking a stand for future
generations
for our children our grandchildren
because what we have
witnessed unfold these last 22 days
is absolutely the single most despicable
display of guilt by accusation we have
ever witnessed
in 32 days this is also about
your life right now you ask yourselves
are you better off than you were two
years ago
because by every reportable objective
discerning measure this country is now
in the middle of a recovery and
boom that is the envy of the world we
learned today
unemployment in america the rate dropped
to the lowest point
in nearly 50 years 1969
the mets won the world series it's now
3.7 percent
we learned that hispanic unemployment
matched a record low
add to that historic low unemployment
for african americans
asian americans women in the workplace
and
youth unemployment record low
unemployment now in 14 states
look at manufacturing manufacturing is
now near
an all-time high 400 000 new
manufacturing jobs jobs that the last
administration said were never coming
back
consumer confidence at an all-time high
four million of our fellow citizens the
forgotten men and women we talked about
so much of in 2016 4 million fewer on
food stamps
four million new jobs created that's
eight million americans we have out of
poverty
the promises of the president that he he
lists and he keeps
his tax cut the largest in history
border wall construction
three billion dollars already spent he's
keeping that promise
the promise on nafta that we get better
trade deals pulling out of obama's
catastrophic iranian deal look at the
progress we've made in the korean
peninsula i don't see missiles flying
over japan every other day
and by the way he's opened up what will
be the might
and prosperity for all of america that
could literally
bring help bring about more peace than
we ever imagined
and that is of course the engine of
every economy we have more
energy natural gas uh oil
and and coal than all these other
countries combined
and for all you never trump republicans
tonight i have a message for you
you had your way none of this would have
happened
and by the way i'm talking about you
so-called conservative republicans
who said i'll never vote for trump
well you can't take your victory lap
tonight you know who you are
you're the ones that they're podcasting
writing books that no one buys
self-promoting yourself as pro-trump
johnny come lately's frankly you owe
real conservatives in this country an
apology why because
if you had your way none of this would
be happening but tonight
as the horrific kavanaugh confirmation
process
demonstrated this election is about so
much more than just
undoing these incredible two years i've
said it before i'll say it again i'll
shout it from a mountaintop if i have to
the single most important midterm
election in our lifetime